die gamescom steht vor der tür und wird
dort seinen jeden tag in der speakers
corner
um 10 uhr in zusammenarbeit mit den
westdeutschen rundfunk interview ich
leute rund um gaming und einer der
ersten gäste wird jan müller-michaelis
seine entwickler von edna bricht aus
oder harveys neue augen auch in dem ein
oder anderen let's play auf youtube zu
sehen und er wird meine fragen
beantworten und natürlich eure stellt
sie möglichst zahlreich und kreativ
gerne auch als video frage unten im
kommentarfeld klicken und dann kann man
rechts auf den button klicken und eine
video antwort also die video frage als
video antwort hochladen ja seid kreativ
ließ den info text und ansonsten wie war
das nochmal moment bleibt dran